البدايه من باريس حيث تجري مواجهات بين
الشرطه ومحتجين على مقتل ثلاثه افراد في
باريس اطلقت الشرطه الفرنسيه الغاز
المسيله للدموع لتفريق تظاهره وهذه صور
المباشره التي نشاهد الان من موقع الحدث
موقع هذه المواجهات بين
المتظاهرين المحتاجين وقوات الامن
الفرنسيا
تستمر اذا هذه المواجهات في ساحه
الجمهوريه وفي محيطها ايضا في العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس العاصمه باريس التي كانت
امس في مصر
اطلق النار قرب المركز الثقافيه الكردي في
المقاطعه الاداريه العاشره وتسبب لمقتل
ثلاثه افراد واصابه ثلاثه
اخرين واعترف ان دوافعه
عنصريه
اذا تحاول احتواء الموقف وتتصدى للمحتاجين
بالغاز الموسيقي للدموع
المزيد ينضم الينا من ساعات الجمهوريه في
باريس مراسلنا حفضل ما اخر تطورات الموقف
لديك
نعم مريم في الحقيقه ثمه مواجهات ما زالت
جاريه بين عدد من المتظاهرين والمحتاجين
الذين كانوا هنا في ساحه الجمهوريه وسط
العاصمه باريس قبل ان يتحولوا الى هناك
الى
توب في اتجاه باسي حيث وقعت عده مواجهات
مع الشرطه حاول همم المنظمون للمظاهره
السيطره على هذه المواجهات لكن يبدو انهم
لم ينجحوا في ذلك وتحولت الى مصدمات مشاهد
الدخان او اعمده الدخان ترتفع الان هنا
وهذه المصادمات ما زالت جاريه بين عدد من
المحتاجين والمشاركين في المظاهره وقوات
الامن
منذ صباح اليوم هنا في ساحه الجمهوريه
وعلى الهمش هذه المظاهره
يوم امس على المركز الثقافي الكردي الذي
راحه همم ثلاثه اشخاص في الحقيقه يتم
تخريب عدد من الواجهات وايضا الاشارات
التجاريه وغيرها بالاضافه الى اضرام
النيران في عدد من المعدات هنا في همم
الشوارع القريبه من ساحه الجمهوريه وسط
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس الى المحتجين
غاضبون من تعامل السلطات الفرنسيه والشرطه
الفرنسيه مع ما وقع المسؤولون الاكراد
يقولون انهم طلبوا من السلطات الفرنسيه
قبل حدوث هذا الهجوم المزيد تعزيز همم
الحراسه وايضا الامن على مقارهم وذلك
بالتزامني مع احترام الذكر العاشره تقريبا
لهجوم منازل راحه ضحيته 10 من الناشطين
الاكراد هنا ايضا في باريس وهم يقولون
انما وقع هو هجوم ارهابي كما يصفون
وادوافعه هي
وايضا عنصريه وكان مرتكب هذا الهجوم
القاتل قد اعترف بانه عنصري خلال عمليه
التحقيق الاوليه معه هو ان توفيعه كانت
عنصريه وانه استهدف الجاليه ال